good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
[Music]
and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody is looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Friday
getting down on
Friday not only is it Friday this is the
most Friday Friday we shall ever have
because it is the final day of the final
week of the show for the year it's the
season of the six and it's coming to a
close I was thinking last night that the
next time we do a toast episode it will
be our seventh season we are back the
first week of January today is our last
episode of the Year Jackie how does it
make you feel to enter our seventh
season it makes me feel proud excited
strong old no wise [__] I wasn't saying
like you you're the only one who's old
sorry sorry I mean cuz you would be
saying the both of us are old I mean I'm
saying we're rebranding old and we're
calling it wise comma
[__] love that comma cap comma the
toast is
bused that no cap that we've been new oh
my God she's 17 she's
17 we've been new that the toast is
busing we've been knowing we've been
knowing yeah toot toot beep beep running
my hands through my
fro oh wow dancing on 2 what song is
that ignition oh
oh I just want to say I just want to say
AR Kell's the worst person on the planet
he is a Monster who should never see the
light of day ever again
however that song is good that song is
buzzing wait also if you didn't just
give me that o face I wouldn't have
realized it was R Kelly who sang it I
just be like I don't know maybe I would
have Googled it probably not so let me
go back to that moment where I was just
singing this fun song called Ignition no
ignition is a very unique song in the
sense that like pretty much everyone
stopped listening to R Kelly like it's
not acceptable like we are all deeply
enraged by what he did like everyone
knows about it but there's something
about that song people can't let it go
well I he has a lot of songs now that
nobody listens to yeah I feel like
ignition kind of slips through the
cracks as not being like so AR Kelly
branded like I Believe I Can Fly is a
toast it's done it's it's R Kelly
through and through but I feel like I
could have thought ignition was by
someone else and I and I might have
thought that no personally I'm just
letting know my Association like for me
I Believe I Can Fly is inextricably R
Kelly I think for most people ignition
is more so inextricably R Kelly got it
okay I'm sorry for those people me too
cuz it's a good song yeah it's Buon it's
so annoying when people who are like
disgusting do something you know like
have a talent yeah as far as losing the
music of a disgraced artist like for us
there was only like three songs for our
Kelly there was two no I feel like
there's a third one I don't know um I
know the third one I believe I can fly
like I could live without I don't really
even like that song no oh that's a loss
for me the world's greatest that's the
third one that was a that was a tough
loss for the community yeah so there's
three it's not like you know anyone who
had to Grapple with Michael Jackson it's
like song after song I never I never
really got into MJ yeah but for the
people who did who also like didn't want
to support his music like that's a lot
of hits to miss out on oh that sucks
yeah
that's what I'm saying so I don't know
how our final episode of the Year became
about our
Kelly but it did and we're just I'm
excited for today's episode you know
what I love is that whenever we take a
break our last episode before the break
always gets like double the amount of
downloads because you know we're
essentially giving people a month like
your maternity leave people had a month
to listen to that last episode yeah this
time around people have three weeks to
listen to the final episode so I want to
make it so good I want to be my best I'm
going to be hilarious try too hard
please like we're best off the cuff
natural and yeah I guess and what's so
exciting is that while the toast won't
be on till the first week of January
there are a few things happening that
should satiate you over the break if
you're a patreon member we have three
episodes remaining for the rest of the
month you will get three episodes while
we are away so what's also exciting even
more exciting I would venture to guess
is if you're not a patreon member if you
sign up today you will get not only
those three episodes afor mentioned you
will get the two that we already
recorded this month and you will get the
hundreds that we have done over the last
six years there's so much content for
you if you're missing y girls now is the
time to join patreon I know you're
probably thinking like I I don't have
patreon what is patreon I've never you
know used the app it's really so simple
go to patreon.com theeast make a login
you do have to make a login you're done
it's all there videos blogs audio
episodes audio video Epis episodes so
many different topics you're going to
find so many things that you love it's
really so simple don't be intimidated by
the fact that it's like patreon you
might not have ever used patreon before
right it's very easy to use it's a
subscription service so it's $7.99 for
the month and you'll get access to
everything we've ever recorded with that
$7.99 so it might be a good way you know
forgo a coffee if you can and get a
patreon
and
and there's more so you can of course
listen to old episodes join the patreon
while we're gone but next week you'll be
able to watch something really special
really fabulous that I recorded not
recorded filmed excuse me I was on set
that I filmed a little while ago my
comedy special will be out you have to
stay tuned for all the details it'll be
on my Instagram you'll be able to find
out every all the details once they come
out um but that'll be next week so it's
just very exciting like we're leaving
you guys we're leaving you guys but
we're also we're giving traits we're
leaving you in good hands I feel we're
not just ducking and running we have
supp systems in place we have Nets after
Nets to help you on your way down back
to January 4th I think would be our
first episode of the year I don't
remember but we'll figure it out I know
we took I know we took a generous lead
time after New Year because we've got to
get back and we've you know get ready I
think it was January 4th but actually
maybe not it's giving fifth fourth okay
fourth yes fourth okay fourth May the
fourth be with you we'll see you then so
don't worry and then we still have
today's episode which is going to be
super fun how are the stories
the stories themselves I wouldn't say
are the strongest batch however they are
all rif for
commentary themselves the stories
themselves are Rife for commentary which
is I prefer rather than like a hard
story of hard news that's like congrats
grads congrads grads or rip or rip like
what more is there to say today we have
five stories and I believe we'll have
something to say about them that's such
good news yeah I thought you would think
so so before we dive in let's talk about
this year okay so I want to say Jax
congrats congrats on making it to the
end of the year I was thinking about
this this morning you know this is a
very challenging year for you you went
through a lot you came out on the other
side stronger and wiser than ever before
and I'm so excited to be spending the
holidays with you and more importantly
your children and I dreamt of them last
night oh and I just I'm really proud of
us like this was a challenging year you
know we talked about this a little bit
on our most recent patreon episode but
just looking at the year out of glance
like you know this year was so important
to remember it could always have been
worse of course that doesn't mean that
you can't remark on a hard on the
challenges you know you were rooted from
your home you had a very complicated
pregnancy tgtg
barem chur made it here with us y but
then we also you
know
Theo Israel Israel it was a challenging
highs and lows we had a great year
workwise the toast is just the toast is
B the the toast is B how did I live
without that word for so long I don't
know but are you going to start using it
like in everyday life of course it is
Bing so if you do want to use it if you
really want to use it correctly most of
the time it's referring to food so you
would say this beef stew is busing my
Sara meals are
busing are they though yes they are okay
they're Hardy oh yeah no if something's
like really Hardy and delicious and
savory it's busing but my beef Su is
busing and I'm so excited because I will
be cooking beef stew on our trip and I'm
going to show you like what I've been
talking about we have been so organized
for our upcoming trip shout out to Margo
and Olivia who have really been carrying
the load corate Queens created a
calendar for us it's colorcoded and they
even got like what who's cooking what
night and what they're making it
literally says like Jackie's beef stew
Ben's Chili it's actually I'm doing the
chili because Ben is on the hook for
like a lot of breakfasts and lunch yeah
that's so Ben but Ben is I mean I would
love to do a chili cook off with Ben I'm
ready I've been preparing for years I
don't know if I've had your chili since
the great chili cookoff which is
available on patreon so if you join
patreon this month you will be able to
go watch it from our family trip like 5
years ago I don't think you have and
even though my chili like I've perfected
it and I I love it I don't know that you
will because it's not taco meat no but
here's the thing I I meant to tell you
this I meant to tell you this a i a week
ago I went over to tayor ster she's like
I'm making my famous chicken chili I'm
like oh great and then I was like will I
like it like I don't know if I actually
like chili chili that's not the one Ben
makes for me which is essentially taco
meat it was so good and it's really not
that different than what I eat so just a
little soup beer yeah and I still ate it
with a fork okay and you could put my
chili like through a sifter get the
Liquid out a strainer a strainer yeah so
we're very excited for our trip what but
we were talking about the year we were
having a nice you were saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah we went to busting but we were
talking about the year so highs and lows
I feel excited about how we're going to
end off the year and I just wanted to
say I love you and I'm so proud of you
for what you really championed you went
through so many hard things this year
and you never faltered in your strength
and your perseverance and you still
remained just so positive and I just
think you're a role model for for young
moms and I love you oh my God that is so
nice thank you honestly like I'm really
excited for the break I feel like I've
been burning out a little bit so it's
really nice to hear you say that um I'm
getting like I'm just like tired it was
a crazy [__] year tired I know but it
was a crazy year and we need to
acknowledge how how much we went through
and how far we came and we I feel like I
grew up a lot this year my year of yes
you've had a big year a year of yes
after 26 years of no cuz she's only 27
thank you thank you and of course this
last quarter has been incredibly
emotionally difficult and no one has
gone through it more with more strength
and Grace and every time someone asks me
like how Claudia is doing I'm like she
is so sad but she so measured like and
levelheaded you know it's you haven't
like lost your mind even though you so
easily could and even this entire time
and so every I know 2024 is going to be
the year of turd and I don't want to
only focus on the challenging Parts
because it was such a great year like
you know professionally personally
Charlie like so many fabulous things
happened this year we're so blessed the
toast everyone just like coming along
for the journey watching being so
supportive always like any the the book
the book The Kimber and the counselor
like we had so many amazing things
happened this year so I don't only want
to focus on the bad it was just a
fabulous year I'm sad that it's coming
to an end my year of yes I do think I
will be bringing the yes energy into
next year I I'm I feel pretty pleased
about the decisions that I made this
year the trips I took the the businesses
I ventured out on like I think it's good
keep saying yes yeah I love that so your
resolution was a success yes that was
like the first time I think I really
followed through on a resolution the
entire year I was just saying that I
have a resolution I already forgot it do
you remember not that you would remember
more than I would but not that I would
remember something you said right that
was like personal to me and I remember
when I you tell me I remember when I
said it you were like you know yuck it
wasn't for you oh what you're going to
start homesteading and making your own
toilet paper no I forget what it was oh
I just remembered something I need to
buy for our trip a souro starter kit no
Duty wipes like I don't know I think I
said this I have from the boys oh I
guess I could steal the kids did I get
wipes in my order you know what I don't
think I did I always forget the wipes I
also wanted English muffins um I need to
I don't know if I've said this on the
toes but your friend Sam who you were
just talking about on your Instagram
story is thank you for the reminder I'm
literally a mother [__] I'm a mother
now you stealing your kid wipes that
they don't even have but back to wipes I
don't know there's already a run on the
wipes I don't know if I've ever said
this thing but your friend Sam's husband
Ben has this like theory about wipes has
he ever told you it I don't know and he
told me at one time and let me tell you
it changed the way like I wipe my ass
forever okay he was just saying like how
crazy it is that like you take a poop
and you just like wipe it with toilet
paper when there's like Duty on your
skin like if you got Duty on your finger
you would run it under hot water scrub
scrub scrub like crazy but there's
literally Duty on your skin in your butt
and like some people just use toilet
paper like it's disgusting
I guess well it's different if with your
finger because you're going to use your
finger again and you want to get okay
let's say you get it on your
arm and just like wipe it off you
wouldn't just wipe it off you would
scrub it technically not that I'm
advocating for uncleanliness but
technically if you're wearing long
sleeve all day and you happened to get
Duty up here and you wiped it off and
then you put your long sleeve back on
and you were going to wash your shirt so
now there's Duty on your shirt but
you're going to wash it just like you
would wash your underwear like yes but
just it's it's funny to think about like
how just very nonchalantly like clean
our asses very haphazardly if you will
when if in any other scenario you got
poop feal matter on any part of your
skin like you would scrub it off and
that was him basically advocating for
wipes I like the advocation but it's
like the part of your body that's
designated for feal matter that you're
not using for anything else so it can
wait until you
shower yes but it's just kind of crazy I
I I love wipes so I'm here for this
anything that's for cleanliness is for
godliness I love Duty wipes like they're
my favorite what do people call them wet
wipes wet wipes no they're Duty wipes in
my
house they're wet uh they're just Wipes
we use the same wipes for really
everything so add it to list needed Duty
wipes for adults and children I will I
just added it to my
cart so we've got a great show I'm like
kind of hesitant to dive in cuz this is
like the last time we'll be able to talk
about ourselves for the rest of the year
oh that's hard but I'm I'm all capped
out on talking about myself for the year
I'm excited I'm taking a vow of silence
except for the three patreon episodes we
have to do and hanging with my family
and of course all the content you're
going to make promoting my special of
course what do you have in mind for me
some Tik toks yes I do have a lot of Tik
toks in mind I'm gonna be torturing
everyone with my Tik Tok this holiday
season that's fine speaking of
self-promotion I just wanted to give an
update because my book I was on Amazon
last night and it's back in stock on
Amazon now I don't know if they were
just doing this to be like thirsty and
you know hype it up but they were like
one copy left I don't really know how
that's possible when it just came back
in stock but it is coming back in stock
oh maybe they weren't lying anyways it
will be back in stock for real before
the holiday so just keep check oh no
arrives before Christmas yeah it's
available now and it doesn't say one
left so the warehouse is busing they got
allies who am
I Claudia with a cold
no I'm the warehouse and I'm sick
because I have all these sick books
inside Meck sick books the camera and
the counselor it's on Amazon it doesn't
say one copy anymore so go get your copy
on Amazon if you want a signed copy I
believe the store books and greetings
where I did my signing still has some
sign copies left so if you want to give
like a very special gift to someone with
a copy with my John Hancock call up the
store and they'll ship it out you can
order it you can order it just call them
go to Google Books and greetings in
Livingston New Jersey call them I know
it's kind of like a rub go way to get it
but like that's the only way you get a
sign copy and it's like you're you're
working hard you're going out of your
way to get a really thoughtful gift for
someone that's not just like buying a
book on Amazon though that works too
that works no and also if you live in
New Jersey you could go to the store
that's true but I feel like everybody
who lives around there came to my
signing came to the yeah so you could
call what if you just called up books
and greetings it's an idea yeah so I
don't know how many copies they have
left but give it a shot whoever you
gifted to would be like
so honored to get a personalized copy
from your girl so all that say before we
dive in all have to say is that even
when we're not working we're still
working and there's always content for
you yes but that's not what I was going
to say alls that to say happy Holidays
happy New Year Jack the end of a chapter
the beginning of a book I love you
dearly and let's dive in oh now you're
ready to dive in yeah was there anything
else no but like two minutes ago you
weren't ready it's crazy what can happen
in two minutes yeah me talking so true
also Hanukkah ended last night I hope
everyone had a happy Hanukkah oh you
know what you know where I went last
night I went to like a Hanukkah it's
like a little Hanukkah party oh I saw it
looked so meaningful it was so nice it
it was the last night of Hanukkah we all
lit candles and it was um we were
hosting a group of they were like
honestly teenagers they must have been
like 16 17 or 18 who all have either
siblings or friends who are currently
being held hostage and they all just
spoke a little bit about their um
experience what they've been doing they
basically just been traveling around the
world they went to the UN that day
advocating for the release of the
hostages and a lot of them were you know
there was their brothers and sisters who
were kidnapped some of them it was their
parents and everybody knows that video
of the the beautiful brunette girl on
the back of that motorcycle being taken
into Gaza after the music festival her
name is Noah um her friend was there and
he was speaking on her behalf and he was
like you know she doesn't have any
siblings her mother has you know brain
cancer so some of her friends have been
she just got back from Australia like
they're all traveling around the world
advocating on her behalf cuz she doesn't
really have a lot of people to do it for
her it was it was very moving um and I'm
really glad that I went it was so and
these kids they're 16 you know they're
so tough like they were speaking and
they like were on the verge of tears but
they didn't let a single tear shed like
they were so tough and so strong and had
such mental fortitude and they were so
young it was so impressive I was like I
was so tired I was like should I go
whatever I was so glad that I went and
they were just like so precious a lot of
them their first time in New York
obviously I think they were wishing they
were here for completely different
reason right but um a lot of like the
Jewish organizations that brought them I
think had planned like fun activities
for them cuz they're still just like
16-year-old kids in New York for the
first time so they went to the Madonna
concert last night at barklay Center and
um really cute I'm so glad that I went
it was an amazing event and I feel like
there was like a couple of days where a
lot of the hostages not a lot but like
some of the hostages were released
mostly the women and the elderly and
people have just kind of forgotten about
all the men there like people's dads it
was most of their older brothers um
there's still 135 people chilling also
any women above the age of 20 yeah what
about them and so one of the girls
speaking both of her parents she was
from kibuts bar which is really where a
lot of yeah and both of her parents were
taken and then her mom was one of the
people released a couple weeks ago and
she's like my mom is here physically but
like mentally she's not okay because one
of all the things she experienced and
two like her husband is still sitting
there and she knows the conditions right
was so heartbreaking these kids were
just so strong I couldn't get over like
how young they were because they just
appeared so mature and so
tough yeah we can't let the energy die
down I feel like that's why they keep
traveling the world and speaking to
everyone like it's just so crazy there's
over 130 hostages of civilians people
who were taken from their bed in their
underwear and being held hostage by a
terrorist organization and that just
seems to be what is it I saw a tweet
that's like what how did the hostages
become the subplot subplot of the war
like they are that's the reason we're in
the IDF is in Gaza like trying to rescue
hostages these kids were these kids were
really frustrated they're like this is
not how we want to be like going through
this experience like traveling around
begging people to believe us and begging
people to Care and Share in our pain
they were like frustrated and like the
fact that they even have to go to the UN
and explain to these officials what's
going on and why it's important to
advocate for the hostages being released
they were they were mad no I would be so
mad did you see the video I saw it this
morning nanyu who's the prime minister
of Israel was meeting with the Red Cross
those yes useless pieces of [__] and he
was like you guys need to put public
pressure on heras to release the
hostages and the Red Cross woman who
this was her first time the head of the
Red Cross her first time going to Israel
since the start of the war said we can't
put public pressure on Hamas if they'll
just close the door to us and he was
like why don't you try right what if you
just tried something no these are people
who have been shot who have been stabbed
who are receiving no medical care who
are sitting in dark dark tunnels who get
no they get medical care from a local
veterinarian right right you shot in the
arm the local vet will Stitch you
up it's beyond so I was really glad that
I went and you're right like we really
can't stop talking about the hostages
cuz while it's great that some of them
have been released the majority of them
have not
right so I was glad that I went it was a
great
event and yeah and anyone who wants
peace like start with hostage release
and then and then maybe we can get
towards peace but there can't be peace
when there are hostages in tunnels in
their underwear with bullet wounds who
have been separated from their family
and kidnapped in the middle of the night
period release release then peace
release then peace then
cease oo I love it would probably be
release then cease then
peace that could work that could work
cap no cap
busing now without further ad to for the
last time in the year after
20202 here are the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by Sunglass Hut it's the
season of giving but finding that
perfect gift can often feel like
searching for a needle in a hay stack we
have found the perfect solution to all
of our gifting woes all the shades of
holiday at Sunglass Hut where it's all
about the magic of gifting nobody has
ever been mad for receiving a pair of
sunglasses one it's just it's a
universal thing everybody loves
sunglasses two there's no sizing like it
works for everybody it's such a good
gift Sunglass Hut has brands from all
different price ranges and they really
carry such fabulous Styles and the inore
experience is really premium I went like
about a month ago about a week ago I us
to see that and I had the best time like
seriously Wendy these sales associate
was so helpful like helping me find my
face shape has changed I used to go for
just like the biggest most oversized
covering my face and she she was like
helping me try on different styles with
like round frames Square frames she was
really helpful really smart and
knowledgeable and she really helped me
find the perfect gift for myself and I
also got YouTu pairs of sunglasses they
have a special holiday gift guide where
you can easily find trendy Versace
shades for your stylish bestie Oakley
shades for your sporty cousin or even a
ray band pair for that iconic person in
your life their gift guide is the best
place to find gifts for everyone and if
you need to show some extra love
Sunglass Hut is the ideal gifting
destination thanks to their
customization and Engraving options you
can let let a friend pick their own and
give them a Sunglass Hut gift card
instead
just talk to the expert sales associates
try out their latest technology both
inline and on store their personalized
Services make holiday shopping a total
Breeze with services like buy now pay
later Sun love protection plan head over
to Sunglass Hut and discover the special
selection of Shades in store and online
at sunglasshut.com they're the perfect
gift for everyone this holiday season
again you can shop in store or online
today's episode is also brought to you
by Wella professionals Wella
professionals has over 140 years of
experience a hair care brand that was
developed initially for professional use
only and previously was only sold in
salons it's consistently ranked among
the top loved Brands by professional
stylists and now you can get your hands
on their products their new line the
ultimate repair is their most premium
lime to date it was developed with over
140 years of experience and researched
to deliver the very best so the miracle
hair rescue repairs hair in only 90
seconds if you use a lot of heat on your
hair and you're always concerned about
how much heat you're using what products
you put in your hair before you style is
so important and I happen to love the
miracle hair rescue from Wella it is key
ingredients like Aha and Omega 9 it
rebuilds the hair bonds inside the
strands and replenishes the outside
barrier of damaged hair their bonding
serum serum repairs hair damage in 90
seconds it's a luxury product it's so
easy to use so I do it when I wash my
hair on my hair wash days like three
times a week before I sit down to blow
dry my hair I'll coat my hair maybe like
10 to 15 pumps of the miracle hair
rescue let it sit for at least 90
seconds and then I just style as normal
my hair feels really good after feels
strong looks really shiny I love this
product also it smells so good it does I
have it in my hair right now tury so do
I um it's easy to apply you can leave it
in all day and it's also safe to use on
colored hair and it can be applied right
after you towel dry your hair so you can
try the ultimate repair Miracle Hair
rescue with 10% off the travel size on
Amazon by using our promo code 10 toast
that's 10 t o a s thank you well today's
episode is also brought to you by better
help whether or not your family gives
gifts during the holiday season you get
to Define how you give it to yourself
the holidays are a great time to do that
so whether it's by starting therapy
going easier on yourself during those
tough moments or treating yourself to a
day of complete rest remember to give
yourself some love this holiday season
you know mental health can be a
challenge during the holiday season some
people find the holidays really
isolating overwhelming anxiety inducing
there's a lot of travel and so taking
care of yourself should not be put on
the back burner and I feel like everyone
gets really busy this time of year
better help makes it so easy to always
be putting yourself first no matter
where you are if you're traveling for
the holiday season because it's therapy
done online if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help at try
it's done entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist at any time for no additional
charge so what's great about better help
is of course you can do it anywhere so
if you're traveling for the holidays or
if you're just like a person with wander
lust you can always you know stay
grounded talk to your therapist and you
can do it on any medium that's
comfortable for you so you can chat with
them via text phone call video chat
whatever you feel most comfortable and
if you're not vibing with the therapist
that they match you with which is
totally normal they let you switch
really easily and it's not awkward so
it's the season of giving and you need
to give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com toast to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp.com toast for 10% off your
first month thank you la you're welcome
our first story a little young
love Olivia Rodrigo and Lis Patridge
confirmed their relationship with a
cheeky make out session in New York City
emphasis on the cheeky yeah it was
giving cheek crack hole it was giving
treat crack hole Olivia Rodrigo
confirmed her romance with her new bow
LS Patridge during a steamy make out
session in New York City the pair both
20 years old good to know were
photographed packing on the key dat
they're Olivia red goes 20 yeah well I
didn't know that but yeah I thought she
was like 24 Oh I thought she was 19
snitch said yesterday she was 19 when we
were talking and how old is Sabrina
Carpenter cuz I also she older she
remember she's an older girl that was in
the lyric oh yeah yeah yeah sa 24 yeah
yeah okay W this is like kind of a very
mature Advanced make out session for 20y
olds like I was not making out with
anyone like this when I was 20 I was
like a freak really I feel like that
this is how like 20y olds make out no
way 20 is so young no you're an
adult you're still in college if you're
not Olivia Rodrigo yeah but so you're on
your way to adulthood college is where
you transition from an adolescent to
adult now let me ask you a question cuz
everybody seemed to know who this leis
Patridge fellow was and I had never
heard of him I don't know her either but
I think he's from the show Inola
Holmes oh in I thought you were saying
in Nola yeah that's why I added the
homes
because that so that you would know yeah
the show is Enola Holmes yeah with
Millie Bobs he's also in Paddington 2o
did you know do you know the origin of
the bear Paddington I know nothing I
just know he's a bear in a raincoat let
me tell you the sweetest story that I
didn't know I always like Paddington cuz
he's a bear in a raincoat and it's so
cute and he did that sketch with the
queen with the queen just remind me I
have something to tell you that I just
found out also okay so basically the
character of Paddington do you know what
the Kinder transport
was that was during the Holocaust during
the Holocaust A A A Train full of German
Jewish kids were sent to Britain to save
them from being exterminated it was only
kids no parents they all came with a
backpack on and a tag around their neck
that like said their name and who they
were and it was called the Kinder
transport and the creator of Paddington
saw those kids and that's why Paddington
is he like is at the train station he
has a tag he's based on the kids from
the Kinder Transport oh my God I'm GNA
cry I'm literally gonna cry so
Paddington is Jewish Paddington is a
Jew and you got to get Harry a
Paddington Bear and he's a
Zionist I'm obsessed obsessed I thought
that was I had no idea the well my my
fun fact is like so dumb compared to you
okay I just found out that Barry Manalo
the singer of at the Copa Copa Cabana
who like looks chewish but I feel like
is not um he is responsible for many of
the famous Jingles on television
including like a good neighbor stay f is
there musical icon I am stuck on
Band-Aid but a Band-Aid stuck on me oh
that's cute yeah remember that one from
when we were going up he was talking
about it in an interview how like a lot
of people don't know that but these are
songs that have been on TV like the
State Farm one for 40 years and he
considers them his Greatest Hits as he
should isn't that cute that is cute
great this a lot of oh Lis Patridge was
in medich I watched that oh he was one
of the younger brothers though I
recognize him okay I mean he's very
handsome fella I just feel like I was
really showing my age but by never
having heard of this person
yeah and also like that we didn't watch
Inola Holmes yeah yeah but the pictures
were really cute they're frolicking
around New York getting her suitcase out
of the car she's holding a box of Ritz
crackers relatable and they're making
out and his finger is like up her butt
and it's cute yeah it's cute they're
they're laughing they look just like a
bunch of kids in love honestly it's like
it's a very cute photo shoot yeah I I'm
so here for what's not to like really
what's not to like really I I mean I
guess she'll tell us when she writes a
song about yeah all of a sudden we're
all hooked on Louis Patrick
right right # L Patrick is over party
blood sucker Fame [__] yeah bleeding
me dry like a goddamn
vampire yeah so let's enjoy it while it
lasts I was actually listening not to
say that her relationship won't last but
I'm just saying you know like it's yeah
what goes up I was watching I was
listening to guts on my way to work this
morning like really it's giving it's
giving female empowerment I was just
like kind of stomping through the street
you know oh It Don't Mean a Thing God
loves [__] embarrass she's so good
like she really is like the real deal
yeah not a one hit wonder not a one- hit
wonder even though I never said she was
a one- hit wonder and what I said was it
was too soon to say whether or not she
would be a one- hit wonder though she
and I disagreed you you thought that
that the game was called already cuz deu
had already come out and there was
because technically she had two hits but
a one hit wonder isn't a technical term
it's like
colloquial no one hit wonder is like a
on hit
wonder it's okay iyus I cannot
relitigate this I cannot reate let's
listen it's the end of the year we're
supposed to be harmonious let's not
bring up acrimonious beefs from years
past but I just I think I feel like the
way that that conversation gets
remembered is I was saying she was a on-
hit wonder when that was never my point
my point was the jury was still out yes
you're right like everybody clowns on
you like Jackie she wasn't a oneit under
but and that isn't what you said but I I
don't feel like a clown cuz I'm like you
guys aren't you guys are not remembering
correctly and maybe if you had a job
that you were passionate about you would
know what it's like but you don't maybe
if you had an argument that you could
argue correctly you would know what it's
like to remember what you said but you
don't you don't but you don't I'm
starving o what are you going to have
for your last lunch of the work day of
the year I don't think I'm going to be
having my last lunch of the year like in
the studio usually I have lunch in the
studio every day but like you'll have
lunch tomorrow it's not your last lunch
of the year
I feel like you should have a twb a warm
bowl yeah to commemorate I'm just like
kind of over the warm bowls like I've
really I I hyperfixated so hard in this
one meal for the last literally two
years and I think I'm actually finally
like kind of sick of it yeah cuz then it
starts to taste like your environment
like it just tastes like work yeah and
you can't change it up because you're
you right it's not like I can get
something else at this place I go to
restant you know a a a
no I go to a restaurant and there's one
if I'm lucky maybe two items that I can
eat this place there's only
one why don't you go to the other place
that we used to go to before the other
place opened I actually had it like like
twice last week but that's a place with
a lot of options you could get a pizza
yeah I know but if I'm going to get a
pizza like okay I'll just go get good
pizza like I don't have to go to the
workplace why don't you go across the
street to the fancy restaurant I should
that place is good but that's reserved
for special occasions like when you're
in town and me you and Harry have lunch
or like a work thing I always take
people to that place yeah but it's a
special occasion it's last work day of
the year okay I just suppose I'm
supposed to go eat by myself um actually
I have my Kindle what's Ben up
to he has a meeting on Long
Island Strong
Island yeah Strong
Island okay are you ready for our next
story is it number two yeah yeah only
number two don't get your brag us in a
twist so this story has my broadcast in
a Twist honestly for real okay Watch
What Happens Live producers remove Andy
Cohen's after show from X after the
platform is deemed not safe due to
anti-Semitism have you seen this I have
it felt so bizarre it's so and random it
counterproductive here's the Deets
producers that Watch What Happens live
with Andy Cohen have pulled their after
show from Elon musk's X formerly known
as Twitter to prevent their content from
showing up alongside anti-semitic posts
page six can exclusively reveal A source
told page six on Wednesday that
production was concerned about their
content living adjacent to inappropriate
hateful or anti-semitic advertising or
content staffers wanted the content to
live in a safe space they're also told
Andy who is Jewish and both an executive
producer and host on the show was
involved in making this
decision honestly this feels like so
performative of Andy like it's just like
making news I don't think it's like
actually making it change and I think we
all know like in terms of the social
media platforms that we should be
advocating against when it comes to
anti-Semitism like X is so not even our
problem yeah everyone has made like X
the poster child for anti-Semitism when
you when if you look at the data the
amount of anti-Semitic anti-israel
sentiment on Tik Tok is whopping and
staggering compared to even Instagram
which is whopping and staggering
compared to X like this is not even we
need a better word than performative
because performative just is like doing
something just you know say that you did
it and not really caring but this is
actually like if you care about
anti-Semitism then it's counterintuitive
it's counter in it's for lack of a
better word dumb yeah yeah it's so true
especially if you're staying on if your
show and you're you still have an
account on Tik Tok then like you make no
sense no it's so true I just read like a
young person like a minor who goes on
the app is like 70% more likely to walk
away after spending 30 minutes with like
a negative view towards Jews and Israel
like the this the data is there the
statistics are there and like nobody
really talks about it everyone's just
sort of focused on on X when like who
car like no one's even on X no but X has
no influence influence and not for you
not for you but it does but that's not
even the issue it's like if you care
about anti-Semitism on social media then
you start at the top you don't start
with the platform that is the least
problematic for what what are you
accomplishing yeah this was just like so
Random like I I don't really feel like
Andy has said or done anything to like
you know about anti-Semitism and so I
think this is like him like making a
statement and I don't think it's saying
much no and he consistently does the
least like does the be he meets the bar
and it's very low but he meets it all
the time and now you want to like step
your [__] up with this yeah like take
an actual stand what does this do for
this doesn't move the needle on
anti-Semitism sorry no it doesn't that's
that's the most important thing it it
doesn't actually do anything and like if
you guys sat down and and the fact that
the staffers want a safe place for their
show like get a grip my friends yeah
yeah they want to sa for their like for
their show about like silliness and
dingdong doorbell gay shark like calm
down yeah you're safe you're safe you're
marked is safe it's just it's just
meaningless yeah but they just like went
nobody asked they went so far out of
their way for like why that's that's it
that's it here's the thing it's it's
layered it's one nobody asked two even
if we did ask like this was the
incorrect move because it doesn't move
the needle it is established that of all
of the social media platforms X is the
least anti-semitic even though you know
people want to frame it to be like Iman
is an anti-semite and there's right he's
really not right when you look into it
he's not but like I guess people don't
look into it is the problem right right
so this looks performative yeah um
having said that Nicki Minaj was on
Watch What Happens Live and she did an
amazing job she's really like such a
character mhm and it was a great episode
what did she do just cuz she's promoting
her album Pink Friday 2 and she was she
watches a lot of Housewives and they
like there was this thing last week
where Kathy Hilton was leaving like
insane comments on Nikki Minaj's social
media being like Nikki please I need to
speak with you and Andy was like did you
ever get in contact with her she's like
I did I don't know what she wants for me
but she had so many nice things to say
about my album so whatever she wants
I'll do I love that yeah Nicki Minaj
whenever she enters the Bravo Universe
really it it brings Joy whenever she
enters anything really like and makes
herself known it's really enjoyable I'm
going to listen to some Nicki Minaj
today while I'm driving that'll be fun
she is like a character I feel like I've
missed out on years worth of music and
driving you know oh because of the car
because I just started driving and now
it's like all these hits from when I was
a teenager when other people were
driving and had the windows down
listening to them like I need to go
experience those moments like I need to
go listen to Pink Friday with my windows
down no you're just like 16 years old
like you're going to be like this one is
for the boys in the boom system like
I've never I've never wrapped super base
from the the driver's seat from the
driver's seat right I know what I'm
doing
today she's catching up yeah that's what
I'm saying she's got some catching up to
do are you ready for our next story this
one is for the
tures in the booma system top down AC
with the cooling system okay wait this
one is for the girls in the this one is
for the boys so this one is for the boys
in the booming system at this point it's
all muscle memory like it's all one word
yeah this one is for the boys and boom
system top toown I see the like it's all
it's like when you learn a song in
another language and you don't know what
the actual words are like what are words
and what are the sentences you just just
keep saying it the sounds yeah yeah but
this song is for the tury not song
story and for the snitch okay should
keep giving
Clues oh am I supposed to be guessing no
but should we do that you know I love a
game you do all right hit me give me
close okay it is I'll give you it was
reported the initial report comes from
deadline that might give you a sense of
like what it's about TV like business
it's for snitch and it's for
tury and it's some buuk
news yes the things we never got over is
being made into a TV show yep Amazon MGM
Studios is developing Lucy score's
bestseller things we never got over for
TV so this is a book that snitch and
tury love and it's just like it was what
it's a similar to me to it happens One
Summer just like swept the world and the
smut World took it by storm it was one
of the biggest like romance books
probably last year yeah agreed and now
it really put Lucy score on the map
she's been like a romance writer for
many many years she has so many books
and I think this was like her first
major hit and then everybody went and
read all of her other books I've read so
many of her books now she's amazing yes
so Amazon MGM Studios is in development
on things we never got over a series
adaptation of the bestselling romance
novel by Lucy score set to adapt the
book and executive produced the show is
Amy rarden from Echo this is the first
book in Amy scores New York Times
bestselling knock himout series which
has sold over 5 million copies in total
wow I thought that was
interesting the second book was not good
I just want everyone to know that well
if the first show is good then maybe the
second one will be made into an also
good show yeah jolly good show I think
it will I actually think this being a TV
show is a great idea I love this and you
just reminded me I saw a video yesterday
inside it was like all the girls who
work at Reese's book club they were like
in the office talking about their work
it literally like if I had to quit and
get a job I would want to work at
Reese's book club they like read all day
their office is so cute it's just like
books everywhere and it's like reading
Nooks everywhere and they love their job
it was the cutest thing ever you know
who needs that job not that she's
looking for a job Stitch Dana yes Dana
needs to be like the work for like
either Oprah's Book Club Reese's book
club or any publication or even if she
worked at a publishing house where she
had to read a bunch of magus scripts
because not only does she love to read
and she reads really quickly and like
actually understands what she's reading
but she's such a good judge of books
like that is the right job for her I
need to use my platform to get her that
job you do it's giving younger or she
could work at book of the month also
because they do the same thing yep but
Reese's book club was just like so
athetic like it was so cute oh yeah for
that her transport's not going to cut it
yeah so so perhaps not but she also
loves her job so so like she's fine you
guys will have to make her really good
offer yeah when she can't refuse or yeah
she could be like read with Jenna's Like
Chief reader right she actually could
probably do that as a hobby yeah as a
side Hustle but back to Lucy score I
just feel like we are always talking
about things getting adapted things
getting picked up book by book wrs being
bought I feel like I never see results
we we see very little in terms of
production well that's something that
happens just because your book gets
bought doesn't mean necessarily it will
get made but I feel like Amazon someone
there
is they have their finger on the pulse
and it's like these books are huge
they's built in audiences I can't
believe more people aren't clamoring cuz
reading has and especially like these
Romance Books these ya novel smut books
like cult
audiences the work is done and the
stories are written like what no and I
feel like two years ago we were talking
about that It Happened One Summer by
Tessa Bailey had been bought also by
Amazon never came true let me check in
on it so many things like they just
you're right they take them off the
market so that like Netflix can't buy it
but they don't always create something
and that's frustrating for like fans of
the books okay this was in June
2022 okay a year and a half ago bcdf
pictures in Frolic media but let me see
but It Happened One Summer yeah they
were producing it so not Amazon so like
those people have to make the movie and
then someone buys it that start so long
ago to have to need to like that's a
year and a half strike and the strike
and it could still happen TL yeah it's
just it's frustrating I wish they would
move faster of
course of course but we have I think
next year it ends with us is coming out
the movie oh yeah you want to hear
something crazy mhm I've never read
things we never got over I don't think
that's so crazy and I don't think you
need to read it because my gripe with it
is that it's too long for a book of its
nature like 700 Pages yeah and it's just
if I'm reading a 700 page book it's Elon
Musk and that's what I'm working on
right now or like The Iliad like right
yeah know I I wouldn't recommend it to
you actually thank you but it's one of
the books when I you know when my
minions come to me and they say chy chy
help us we want to get it into smut it's
probably like the fifth book I recommend
only because it's very long yeah and the
first one is It Happened One Summer it
HP actually I just went through this
hold on because somebody was texting me
like I'm going on my honeymoon I want
like sexy
books um that's a good post to do on
redheads like hone we've done honeymoon
but not sexy honeymoon picks oh I also
say uh crossing the line by Lucy
score but yeah It Happened One Summer
and then probably a co-o is in there um
sometimes I recommend ug ugly love but
once you really get into smut you
realize Colleen Hoover is actually not
smutty at all I never read ugly love oh
I I loved
it I think my last
co-o was November 9th
and then I had had
enough November 9th was cute yeah all
right so hopefully this one comes to
fruition cuz did you ever read really
popular did you read Leela no it was
cute you should it's about a ghost yeah
but it's they make it make sense I know
just one thing about me is like what
I've learned especially this year by
reading like a couple books that are not
based in extreme reality things with
magical realism like I don't like I
didn't like one Italian summer I didn't
like
iron flame but you liked him five years
that's the only one I was just going to
say you like fourth
Wing yeah like the second half and you
like nothing to see here I did like
nothing to see here I didn't like the
measure okay so it's just a book
dependent yeah I guess such as life
don't just write things off flat turd I
won't are you ready for our next story
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by skims per chance it is oh my gosh
if I was a braver woman I would show you
my bra right now because it's the new
skims bra and it's do it do it but just
believe me just trust and believe your
girl skims is creating the next
generation of underwear loungewear and
shapewear and we are two girls with with
bodies you know we don't have like
bodies we have bodies like our bodies
have been through things we need support
Jackie's breastfeeding like we can't
just wear bras you you can't just like
go to a store and buy a bra off the
shelf no we need to wear brazers made by
women for women for women and skims bras
I mean I've said this story about how my
back problems literally were because I
was wearing the wrong bra I didn't even
know and then I got the T-shirt bra that
fits everybody one from skims and it
Chang my life like wearing it today I
got two more actually yesterday in new
colors your favorite your favorite skim
Staples like the fits everybody
collection the cotton collection the
soft Lounge collection the sleep
collection they are all now available in
cheerful holiday colors and festive
Prints Plus skim signature holiday
collections are back for the season and
designed for the whole family the reason
I love skims one of many is that they're
super siiz inclusive so they have size
extra extra small up to 4X for women and
they have unisex Styles and they start
at newborn sizing for children Styles
you'll never be this cozy at home for
the holidays they make holiday shopping
so easy with styles for everyone in the
family skims holiday gift shop is the
destination for all your gifting needs
believe the hype they have over 100,000
festar reviews for a reason skims
holiday gift shop is now open at
skims.com plus get free shipping on
orders of over $75 after you place your
order be sure to let them know that the
toast sent you select podcast in the
survey and be sure to select our show in
the drop- down menu that follows today's
episode is also brought to you by State
Farm as Barry Manalo would say like a
good neigh State Farm is there at the
Copa the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create an affordable price
just for you the plan's all about being
personal to you and your needs that
means you're going to get the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences think
about it like this from your go-to
coffee orders to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do from you know I won't get I feel like
I keep bringing up the tacos and it's
like maybe going to become a point of
contention for us so you know from what
we like to eat to what we wear Jackie
and I are so we even move on to lunch I
like a warm bowl Jackie's doing a meal
plan like we have different needs
because we're different people and Steve
Farm gets that like we're different
people therefore our insurance should be
different and it should be personalized
to us clearly personalization just makes
any anything and everything better
better State Farm believes that
insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage and your selections
can all be personalized by you and
that's what makes State Farm enloy not
like other insurance like they get it
they get how Personal Insurance can be
enloy maybe they'll move over the Barry
Manalo jingle to enloy like a good
neighbor State Farm is there prices vary
by state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
like a good neighbor State firm is there
today's episode is also brought to To
You by The Farmer's dog the farmer's dog
makes and delivers fresh healthy dog
food it's developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and made from
real healthy ingredients to human food
safety standards the results of
switching your dog's food from kibble to
Fresh can seem like magic when a senior
dog starts acting like a puppy again and
the pickiest of eaters cannot wait for
dinner time you might think that some
spells were cast but the farmer's dog
doesn't use any sorcery they just use
science it's the best option for dogs at
all life stages because it's not kibble
it's not canned goo it's just real
healthy food traditional dry and wet dog
food options are highly processed and
they can use much lower quality
ingredients than they claim to and
they're really difficult to portion
accurately so you don't know if your dog
is undereating or overeating but the
farmer's dog they're not just fresh
higher quality food they're also going
to send you the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs this makes it
easy to help your dog maintain their
ideal weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life dogs
at a healthy weight live up to 2 and a
half years longer than overweight dogs a
fresh diet has been found to have all
sorts of benefits from healthier coat
and skin better breath easier digestion
smaller better poops a healthy diet
isn't just for humans and it doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you live more
healthy happy and full years together I
am triggered get 50% off your first box
of fresh healthy dog food at
thefarmersdog.com toast for what it's
worth Theo loved his Farmers dog food it
was really the highlight of his day plus
you get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free shipping thank
you Farmers dog thank you lard yeah
welome our next story Prince Harry wins
his
lawsuit uh against the mirror saying
I've been told that slay dragons will
get you burned so oh God he had to go
and be cringe he did it's a kind of good
saying I've never heard that before what
say it again slain dragons will get you
burned is that good or bad I don't get
the phrase it's like you can't you know
do anything worthwhile without taking a
couple punches
something okay Prince Harry speaking out
after his lawsuit win against the UK
newspaper publisher over allegations of
phone hacking and other unlawful acts oh
wow yeah the Duke of Sussex was awarded
$180,000 he was unable to be president
in London's high court on Friday due to
the short notice of the hearing
according to his lawyer however he
issued a long and Powerful statement
that was read aloud at the
courthouse quote well phone hacking is
insane it reminds me of you know I wish
I was a tampon inside your vagina right
but that wasn't a hacking no it was just
like a bad coincidence yeah it was
nothing illegal was done because you
know before I realized that they had
like actually done something illegal I
thought he was suing for like slander
and you know liel I'm pretty sure yeah
he is currently involved in three other
cases against newspapers in the UK
including the daily mail but I had seen
some headlines that some things like
weren't going his way and that so I was
surprised to see this today because I
didn't realize there was four different
ones but if in their documentary they do
talk about a couple of the different
lawsuits but I think the Daily Mail they
publish are they the ones that publish
the
letter which letter that Megan oh or
yeah that Megan wrote her dad yeah maybe
that's what they're suing over there so
the thing is is like for for actual
things like hacking into like breaking
the law you absolutely should sue but I
always find it so interesting anytime I
get into like Harry and Megan and just
the Royals in general how much reverence
they have towards the tabloids and
British media and it might be a cultural
difference because to me the mirror is
the same as like Okay magazine like I
would never read something in Okay
magazine and be like oh my God Angelina
Jolie is you know a mother of 10
children like they just say like such
absurd things and I'm always surprised
how much weight and like difference the
Royals put on British tabloids and maybe
it's a cultural difference and maybe
British tabloids carry more weight in
the UK it is we've had this conversation
and people always chime in it was also a
big part of their documentary just like
tabloid culture there is not what it is
here and it's very much taken seriously
and the Royals like play their part in
it too like they work with them yeah for
story so it's like a necessary evil it's
just it's different there I still don't
understand it I can but I can understand
it's different no but that's really
insane like to hack someone's phone so
like honestly good on him for suing and
and pursuing this and winning
um yeah he wrote a long statement
dragons you want to read it um it's
really
long so sure I I'll read it until like
we feel like I should stop okay
this case is not I feel like you should
stop I could read it with gusto no no
read it read it read it this case is not
just about hacking it is about a
systemic practice of unlawful and
appalling Behavior followed by clever
ups and destruction of evidence the
shocking scale of which can only be
revealed through these proceedings the
journey to Justice can be a slow and
painful one and since bringing my claim
almost 5 years ago defamatory stories
and intimidating tactics have been
deployed against me at my family's
expense he should have used our line
about the wheels of Justice you know yes
but I have to say this is actually a
very well-written statement and so as I
too have learned through this process
patience patience is in fact a virtue
especially in the face of Vendetta
journalism my commitment to seeing this
case through is based on my belief in
our need and our Collective right to a
free and honest press and one which is
properly accountable when necessary that
is what we need in Britain and across
the globe anything else is poisoning the
well for a profession we all depend
upon okay there he left me there a
little bit at the end but you got the
just yeah good job see the wheels of
Justice their thing yeah no can't be
hacking sorry can't be hacking no not
cool not cool are you ready for our
fifth and final
story wow Fifth and final story for the
fifth and final episode of the Year well
no you know what I mean yeah I'm right
yeah did I it's not the it's not the
fifth and final episode of the Year oh
it's the 205th and final episode of the
Year actually I wonder what episode
number we are
at I think it's like 200 I think
yesterday was 24 oh so this year yeah
trip the fifth and final story of the
205th and final episode of the Year let
me triple check but you can start
reading but even if it's not the case
tury just like go with it I just want to
be factual and let people know but like
who would know unless it's more don't
diminish our credit today's oh we're
about this is our 208th episode episode
of the year that's insane no it's it's
absolutely Bonkers Bonkers it's Madness
it's crazy how much we podcast I know
and the fact that people still listen is
nuts no no no of course you do what else
are you doing what else what else is
there to do what else is there to listen
to nothing our fifth and final story
which I feel passionate about and I hope
that you will at least pretend to
because it's cute stuff okay okay it's a
little collab news a little retailing
collab there will be a Bridgerton theme
collection launching at William Sonoma
for gentle readers everywhere oh that's
cute I was when you were saying a bridg
and collab with I was like who's it
going to be I thought maybe it would be
that brand of like Prairie dresses that
everyone's obsessed with Hill housee oh
that's cute or like self or Love Shack
fancy that would also be cute yeah but
this is better cuz I immediately went
clothing because the clothing and burger
chain is like such a main part of it but
this is so cute it's so good there are
so many products varying in like
seriousness and price and they're and
it's like the vibe of Bridgerton is so
good so you have to wait until May 2024
as we know to watch the next season but
you can start spilling the literal tea
right now on Friday Williams Sono
released an exclusive collection of
foods table wear baking mixes and Gifts
inspired by the Netflix series which is
said among London High Society in the
early 1800s so they have like sweet
treats that you can get like cookies and
biscuits and um CU William Sonoma does
also sell food but they also have like
tablescapes so tablecloth
they what's the vibe like oh it's um
like girly swirly tea party oh tea party
florals that's really cute I think I'm
going to get this tablecloth cuz I have
a round table and I need a tablecloth
and it's so cute and these plates I love
like I feel like collabs have gotten to
a point maybe like Barbie ruined collabs
it was just like so exting barie ruined
collabs it just like nothing was
original nothing was special and I feel
like now collabs are just kind of like
meaningless but this is a like these are
two Powerhouse Brands I don't think
William Sonoma does like a ton of
collabs and Bridgerton I don't think
ever has and they're two brands with
such like distinct brand identities that
bringing them together and they're two
brands with like huge followings I love
this but also like William Sonoma it's
quality stuff it's not just like here's
a bunch of burgerton crap yeah no it's
like everything is made well and it's
you know it's pricey but you're you get
what you pay for yeah so you want
William Sonoma quality Tings but like
with the Bridgerton style because it's
gorgeous and pany
yeah I'm personally am obsessed and they
also really cute they have this
Bridgerton picnic basket this one's $350
so cute I mean who on God's green diddly
dally earth needs a pis picn my God I'm
having a stroke picnic basket mhm no I
don't know especially one that's like
not insulated yeah know I guess it's for
people who just like romanticize their
life and like throw cheese in a bagette
into a thing and go to the park right
but also for people who like romanticize
their life for Instagram who make cont
content who make content and I just want
to say like kudos to those people even
though they're like you it's so hard to
like make content and like to do things
like that and make it look nice cuz I
saw someone not to for the third day in
a row bring on bring up homesteading but
I saw someone was like clowning on
ballerina Farm because it's like she's
you know doing all these things and
making content it's like it's hard
enough to make your own bread and raise
seven children while you're pregnant
with your eighth but you're also filming
all of it in a quality way and putting
these videos together that are like so
aesthetic kudos to you ballerina Farm
okay then there was like something
something else about ballerina Farm
people were like mad because they found
out her husband's dad like started Jeet
blue or whatever and she's like not a
real farmer or whatever because she
comes because she has access to money
okay like I'm jealous like I'm not what
am I actually going to do kill her cuz
she married someone rich like who cares
and it's and I saw a comment that she's
like uh authentic to the homesteading
life inauthentic to homesteading life
cosplaying being poor but it's like
I think she really lives this life and
she's showing other people who might
like need these tools how to do it and
she's making it look manageable also and
they're like she has nannies probably
they're just not in the frame the woman
has seven kids and she's pregnant with
her eighth that's insane and she's
making her own dinner
rolls no like the way whatever the
opposite of like homesteading Mom is is
what I'm going to be like come on kids
we're going to McDonald's like I just
can't I like who's the energy just wait
30ty just wait until you have you work
so hard to have a child and you want to
try and give them everything that's good
for them and not poison them like that's
how it starts to feel but a little
poison is good but then sometimes you
see the joy of a friend try and here
like yeah go go in yeah yeah you know
what like anything else in life balance
I agree I mean I'm sure that ballerina
Farm gets in her car and drives over to
McDonald's and houses a McFlurry I'm
sure of it I mean I don't know how you
can have seven kids and just not you
know just to keep your sanity yeah but I
also saw her pantry like she is your
name ballerina so that's her handle okay
but like who's ballerina oh I don't know
I've I've only encountered her in the
last few days so I'm sure there's a lot
about her that I don't know but I'm so
impressed with this woman and like
people try and like diminish her
accomplishments like even if she just
had seven kids and sat on her ARS all
day yeah yeah yeah while pregnant with
the eth right her name is Hannah and
she's a former juliard ballerina wow
turned
Rancher where does she live she lives it
doesn't say immediately in her
bio but like in the west is it like
Wyoming Vibes yeah yeah yeah she lives
on a ranch Daniel and I are in charge of
the morning milking the boys do the
night milking it's a 20-minute
opportunity we get to spend with each
other sitting on either side of our milk
cow lady we talk about our goals make
decisions
breathe it's beautiful
I don't know if I'm milking a cow I'm
like down there I'm certainly not
breathing well she said breath but I
feel like that was a typ but what do I
know um cool like so interesting to see
how how other people live you know yeah
I I find it just interesting and I also
want to say someone told me I I guess I
hadn't gotten to this on Becca
Martinez's homesteading Instagram
account yeah you severely undersold
Becca Martinez's home make homesteading
she raises
rabbits to eat and SK and repurpose in a
in a good way you know not in like a
Jeffrey dber
way I guess that's cool like okay cuz
she's doing it she's out here doing it
she's doing it she's doing the thing and
I just respect to the homesteaders
respect to the co miners they could
never respect to the mothers yeah it's
all so I'm saying what was the story
richardon Williams TOA now cute I thst
it out for William Sona before on the
show and and they don't listen but maybe
someone at Bridgerton PR and collabs
like wants to send me something in the
me want something I will be buying the
tablecloth though because I need it cute
cute really cute you love to see good
collabs you just there's nothing there's
nothing better than a good pointed
collab and there's nothing worse than
crap on
Ice crap on a
stick crappity crap crap crap in your
lap anything to not end the show I know
you guys our episode is over it is like
I just think it's important to
acknowledge the space that you're in
like it's over we're done goodbye and on
the one hand I want to stay in this
space because it's a good feeling so
much we've accomplished these this year
208 episodes plus uh 12 times plus 70
plus on patreon plus any you know guest
episodes we've done that's a a lot of
podcasting it is
so lay us to rest toast season six
that's a wrap 12 * 5 is 75 no I don't
[__] know no I thought it was 72 but
it's
math is so hard yeah but there's one
equation that's solves them all one plus
one equals sock every time every time so
I just wanted to say to everyone I hope
you enjoy the holiday season with your
families or whoever you choose to spend
it with we love you so much thank you so
much for going on this Journey with us
we hope you enjoyed every episode this
year I hope you enjoyed this particular
episode thank you for being toasters
Jackie and I are so grateful for you
guys we are looking forward to our break
but we are so looking forward to coming
back next year bigger and better and
better than ever better than ever and we
love you seriously we say it every day
but we mean it with our whole chests
thank you for listening to the show in
any way every day once a week once a
month and we prefer it every day but we
really we love you yeah get do better
but you know you got you're busy people
and you take the time to listen to us
and it it's really it means a lot a lot
it really does I love you tury thank you
for the kind words you said about me at
the top of the show I didn't even get to
repay them thank you for holding I
didn't say them I didn't say them for
anything in return that is beautiful
thank you for holding it down while I
was on maternity leave while I was out
you know sewing up my cervix and making
sure the show must go on and you do it
with class and Grace and we all we all
love you so much
and in the words of Tony bra and Jacks
you mean the world to me you are my
everything you are the only thing that
matters matters to me I'm going to go
listen to that in the car
it's and the words of our Kelly yeah I
made it you're the world's
greatest and in the I'm that star up in
the you just can't stop singing I'm That
Mountain Creek up high hey I made it I'm
the world's
greatest the world's greatest podcast
stream tury's version not our Kelly's
version so we can still enjoy the song
but proceeds go nowhere near Mr Kelly
yeah I think that's called compromise so
for the very last time this year thank
you so much for listening to the toast
of Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio I hat radio
castbox all the places so wherever you
listen to podcast find us the toast
[__] and leave a five star
[__] review all
right I bet have beautiful setting and
mully talented we are have an amazing
holiday break we love you dearly and
we'll see you on the next one love
bye